et face à cette invasion russe de
l'ukraine des manifestations de soutien
au peuple ukrainien se déroule ce week
end à travers l'europe c'était déjà le
cas hier à prague et à francfort aussi
en allemagne ce samedi c'est à paris
notamment qu'un rassemblement se déroule
ses place de la république on va
retrouver en direct justement de la
place de la république notre journaliste
elise marne et bonjour élise héliski les
lames oublie l'état de la mobilisation
autour de whisky qu'est ce qu'il y a du
monde place de la république
il y à beaucoup de monde place de la
république ça fait plus de deux heures
que les gens affluent et continuent à
affluer ici non place de la république à
paris la place est intégralement revêtue
de bleu et de jaune pour l'occasion les
gens sont venus porter plusieurs
messages alors un message très générale
de solidarité avec le peuple ukrainien
qui accompagne le hashtag stand with you
crâne mais aussi des messages plus
ciblés nous avons rencontré une
ressortissante ukrainienne qui réside à
paris sa famille se trouve actuellement
dans le sud de kif elle est venue porter
un message de solidarité appelé la
france et les pays de l'union européenne
à ne pas oublier l'ukraine nous avons
également échangé avec un monsieur un
petit peu plus tôt qui lui venait plutôt
porter un message humanitaire il se dit
prêt à accueillir des réfugiés ukrainien
à tout moment enfin nous avons rencontré
le député européen rappelle et
glucksmann lui porter un message plus
politique il a appelé également l'union
européenne à se montrer solidaires
également et militairement avec ce qu'il
appelle la résistance et craignent anne
pour lui si l'ukraine cède c'est la paix
dans toute l'union européenne et dans
toute l'europe qui est qui est menacée
un deuxième rassemblement est également
prévu dans le 14ème place denfert
rochereau dont vous le voyez ici à paris
les couleurs de ce samedi sont vraiment
le bleu et le jaune
merci beaucoup elise marne et pour
toutes ces explications viry de la place
de la mersey